oh my gosh i never watched these again
that's so funny hey y'all i'm erica
thompson from texas b works or you might
know me as that beekeeper from tiktok
i'm here today to answer all of the
questions that has twitter buzzing this
is b support
john edward diver asks question for
beekeepers can they be trained to attack
specific individuals asking for a friend
all right john
and john's friend bees
can actually be trained to recognize
human faces they have actually been
shown to remember those faces for up to
two days it's extraordinary there's
so much we don't know about bees and
it's
fascinating to think of all the things
that we still have yet to discover about
bees and as a beekeeper
it kind of warms my heart too and to
think that they might be able to
recognize my face is is just an
extraordinary feeling
at sweet jess outlander asks how do you
come by extra spare queens and if they
would have had their own queen what
would have happened to the spare this
colony would not survive without a queen
but luckily i had an extra one on me i
could give them it's really the
responsible thing to do as a beekeeper
to have some extra queens on you and i
actually have one on me now
this is a queen bee and she is in there
with three of her attendant bees those
are female worker bees that will take
care of her for her trip out to me and
to meet her new colony and what's
happening inside of this queen cage is
we have a little tube and that tube is
filled with fondant so it's just candy
it's high in sugar and that will provide
the bees food inside the cage once i put
this box inside the new hive the other
bees will chew their way through that
piece of candied fondant and they will
release the queen when they're ready for
her this gives all the bees time to get
used to the new queen's pheromones
giving them a little bit of extra time
by keeping her in this box hopefully
means that the new colony will have a
higher chance of of accepting their new
queen at cameron coral i watched bee
movie not sure how accurate that is at
be experts help how long do we have um
okay hold on can you feel my blood
boiling no i am here to tell you that
the b movie is incredibly inaccurate the
main character is named barry the bee he
is a male bee male bees have one job
that's to mate with a queen male bees do
not forage for food they don't help
raise the baby bees they don't defend
the hive they don't even have stingers
female worker bees are called worker
bees for a reason they do all the work
for the hive i'm a huge jerry seinfeld
fan i love everything he does
this was not the best b movie we can
make a better b movie if you need my
help
the bees and i are here however we can
to help
at ripley mars asks how do bees decide
who impregnates the queen do they hold a
b olympics in some way yes the strongest
fastest drones win and those are the
male bees that get to meet with the
queen once a male bee does mate with the
queen if he's the winner of the b
olympics his life is over as soon as a
male bee mates with a queen his
endophallus rips out of his abdominal
cavity and he falls to the ground and
that is the life of the winner of the b
olympics
at micro pipettes asks the bees abandon
their hive in our garden and i'm
heartbroken why did they have to leave
first of all i am so sorry that your
bees left i know the feeling
it's awful colony loss happens as a
beekeeper whether you're the best
beekeeper in the world or not the bees
are wild creatures they can decide for
themselves you know we're not locking
them up in the hives or forcing them to
stay anywhere as a beekeeper it's our
job to give bees the resources they need
so they can do the important work they
do of course
the bees always know best and so if they
decide to leave that's their choice and
i encourage you to get more bees and try
to start over next spring
at cipher unnamed asks bees bugs how do
beekeepers just scoop up the bees more
importantly why well you know there are
a lot of different methods for handling
bees or doing bee removals and
personally i just feel like scooping up
the bees is you know one of the easiest
most humane ways to get bees from one
location to another a lot of the times
the bees will let you do that perfectly
fine and if they do sting you you know i
just stop what i'm doing and i correct
either myself or i try to do something
different and just always try to listen
to the bees
at izzod how do beekeepers know what
flowers their bees go to how can you be
sure it's leatherwood honey
bees hashtag honey
knowledge one of my favorite things
about bees is that they are flower loyal
in beekeeping we actually call it flower
fidelity what that means is that a bee
on a single foraging trip will go to the
same plant or flower and forage from
that flower exclusively while we don't
always know which bees are going to
which flowers all the time so for
example in california when beekeepers
place hives in the almond orchards to
pollinate the almond crops there's a
pretty good bet that those bees are
almost exclusively visiting those almond
trees and therefore we get these
varietals of honey one of which is
leather wood honey
at super crispy dj asks hashtag
beekeeping question it looks like we
have many bees going in and out of a
grate in our external cavity wall three
ish a minute
sorry
i just realized that they're timing the
rate of the bees going in and out of the
wall and i i just think that's great the
walls got filled with insulation a while
back will bees be safe in there well you
know if you see bees entering this wall
cavity it means that is a spot that
these bees have chosen to live while i
try to not give this sort of beekeeping
advice from afar without actually seeing
the situation the bees and the hive up
close you know if the bees are choosing
that spot to them it's a good spot for
them to live and if they don't bother
you you know i would say the best thing
to do is to just leave them be but if
you want them to be removed or relocated
call a professional beekeeper like
myself and they can best help you
at amir as rule asks how do beekeepers
calm bees hashtag random thought well
one thing that we do to calm the bees is
we use a bee smoker we'll fill the smoke
with some natural materials and we'll
light the smoker and before we enter a
beehive we will give the bees a little
bit of smoke and what that's going to do
is it's going to mask the alarm
pheromones that the guard bees might
send out to all the other bees to let
them know that there might be an
intruder coming into their hive
at the hungry rn asks how do bees decide
to build a nest like do they just meet
and decide to all move out together
okay i hope this answer's gonna blow
your mind you might think that bees
operate as more of a monarchy with the
queen in charge making decisions and
delegating to the worker bees that's not
the case a bee colony is in fact a
democracy the worker bees all make
decisions for the collective good of the
colony so when bees decide that they
need a new place to live they will send
out scout bees and these scout bees will
go forage for the best locations for
their new hive so you've heard the term
hive mine maybe and that's what we're
referring to here a beehive is a super
organism it operates as a whole the bees
as individuals don't really think for
themselves they operate in ways that are
good for the survival of the colony and
for the species
at maxo series art asks are we messing
up the bees with eating honey what's up
well here's what's up experienced
beekeepers can absolutely responsibly
harvest honey from beehives we do it all
the time you know i was lucky to realize
early on in my beekeeping journey that
it just wasn't my favorite thing about
being a beekeeper and so i've made the
choice to to not sell honey each bee in
her entire lifetime only makes 1 12 of a
teaspoon of honey it's such a small
amount they make this honey as a surplus
of food for them for them to survive
during the winter or when we're in a
dearth when there's nothing in bloom and
when there's nothing for them to forage
from while you certainly can harvest
honey responsibly you know and enjoy
honey responsibly and one of the best
ways to do that is to buy honey from
your local beekeeper it's a great way to
support your local bees and your local
beekeeper at miss lindsey lee asks how
do beekeepers get into beekeeping
hashtag bee emoji i can tell you my
story you know as a kid i spent a lot of
time in my backyard collecting bugs and
putting them in a jar and trying to keep
them as pets or trying to study and
observe them and it was really just this
lifelong love of bugs that led me to
start a beehive in my backyard in
central austin and here i am
a full-time professional beekeeper
2010 forever says going absolutely nuts
for the holidays maybe this local honey
will help my allergies well 2010 forever
i have some news for you the theory that
honey helps with your local allergies
because by eating some of this pollen
you will therefore be desensitized to it
can't be applied here because bees
aren't even foraging from the plants
that are causing your allergies things
like hay ragweed cedar these are not the
plants that bees love the most they are
going to other plants so you're not even
getting a little bit of the pollen that
you think you're getting
at your good karma says i wonder how
often beekeepers get stung i know it's a
lot because the bee will sting you for
no reason that's not the truth bees will
not sting you for no reason they will
sting you if they feel threatened or if
they are trying to defend their colony
as a beekeeper i live and work around
bees all the time
getting stung is
pretty much an occupational hazard at
this point people always ask me how many
times i've been stung and
countless countless numbers of times
when you get stung by a bee that stinger
sticks in your skin and at the end of
that stinger there's a little venom sac
and in that venom sac is something that
we call melatonin and that melatin is
what causes the pain so if you get stung
by a bee stay calm don't swat don't
flail around but remove that stinger
at
how do you do that without protection
you seem so relaxed and at ease you are
clearly in your element and at one with
what you are doing it's amazing you
should absolutely wear protective
beekeeping equipment especially when
you're starting out it takes a lot of
time to build confidence and everybody
should always wear protective equipment
around bees
this was such a fun removal the bees let
me work alongside them on this day
without wearing protective equipment and
i was so thankful they let me do that
because i'm in texas it's hot here it is
even hotter in these backyard sheds
where i'm always removing bees from so
the beekeeping gear it's big and it's
bulky and it has to be that's what
protects you from getting stung when
you're in that gear you also lose a lot
of visibility in the veil or dexterity
in the gloves the dexterity especially
is so important when you're working with
such tiny creatures so i absolutely feel
you know most comfortable and confident
when i'm around a colony of bees i know
it sounds crazy but it's it's really
almost meditative
at jay-z love asks question for
beekeepers once i open raw honey do i
have to refrigerate it no do not
refrigerate your honey think like a bee
bees always keep their hive at around 95
degrees store your honey in a dark warm
place and it'll be just fine
atval juristic asks how much do
beekeepers make
well there's an old adage among
beekeepers and that's there's no money
in honey bee keeping is a passion for
sure and it's something that people do
because they love bees and because they
love the work
at insomniac asks how do beekeepers find
the queen between a million bees so the
queen bee is the largest bee in the hive
and on top of that you know her body is
different but she also has a different
job so she's moving differently she's
laying eggs and she usually has a circle
of attendant bees around her the bees
will fan a pheromone out of the back of
their abdomen to let all the other bees
in the colony know that this is where
the queen is this is where you need to
go it's extraordinary to see and once
you start to see the bees do that you
can kind of pinpoint the location of the
queen if you don't already have her yet
in the case of the washing machine
removal you can see a lot of the bees
are on the outside of the washing
machine there and they were all sending
me the signals that the queen was inside
the machine still so i first started to
spend my time looking there and sure
enough you know i found her pretty
quickly but i got really lucky with that
one
at kingdemic asks why are bees so
important to the circle of life bees
provide an extraordinary service to the
planet when they go around to flowers
collecting food they're pollinating
these plants and they're allowing these
plants to reproduce and to survive over
75 percent of plant species on earth
depend on bees or other pollinators in
some way for survival you know if you've
had an apple or an almond or a cup of
coffee you have bees to thank for that
there are over 20 000 species of bees on
the planet as creatures who share the
planet and are susceptible to the
decisions that humans are making for
them they're feeling the effects of
things like climate change habitat loss
and of course the use of pesticides and
agricultural practices
at wira bennett asks would wild species
substitute effectively in agricultural
pollination the story one hears is that
bees are particularly needed in that
role well that's the story you hear
because that's the truth bees are
pollinating with a force and on a scale
that no other insect or animal is and
that is why we use them for these mass
agricultural practices for for mass
pollination we have designed our food
system in a way that we are reliant on
bees for the important work they do
which is just one of the many reasons
that it's so important that we do
whatever we can to help bees there are
some simple things that anybody can do
if they want to help honeybees first and
foremost you can plant food for bees so
whenever you're choosing anything to
plant in your yard or in your garden
make sure it's something that bees can
forage from don't use pesticides in your
own yard or garden support legislation
that bans these pesticides and buy honey
from your local beekeeper take a class
learn about bees do whatever you can to
support your local bee population
in your local beekeeper
so those are all the questions for today
i had so much fun talking bees with
y'all thanks for watching bee support